wenn ich von elektrischen autos spreche
dann denken viele erstmal an sowas hier
oder das hier oder das hier elektrisch
betriebene autos wirken immer noch mehr
die ein spielzeug als eine wirkliche
alternative zu richtigen benzin und
dieselautos aber genau das werden sie
gerade eine solide alternative und eine
bedrohung für das auto von heute der
kampf um den antrieb der zukunft hat
bereits begonnen
aber das ist nicht der erste kampf um
den antrieb der zukunft anfang des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts als das auto
noch eine brandneue erfindung war sind
nur zirka ein fünftel aller autos mit
benzin gefahren zu jeweils 40 prozent
fuhren autos elektrisch oder sogar noch
mit wasserdampf jeder zu der zeit hätte
darauf gewettet dass die zukunft des
automobils elektrisch ist sogar die new
york times hielt das elektroauto damals
für mit abstand die beste wahl
es war leiser sauberer und auch
kostengünstiger und mit führenden
wissenschaftlern wie nikola tesla und
tom ist edison die hinter den elektro
autos standen schien der weg geebnet
wäre da nicht dieser eine mann henry
ford und mit ihnen das erste automobil
das sich nicht nur reiche schnösel
leisten konnten mit hilfe der erfindung
des fußballs konnte er seine autos die
models wesentlich günstiger herstellen
als die handgefertigten elektrischen
modelle der konkurrenz nur sechs jahre
nach dem verkaufsstart des modells
fuhren 99 prozent aller autos in amerika
mit verbrennungsmotor und jetzt ein
jahrhundert später hat sich daran immer
noch nichts grundlegendes geändert
nach dem motto if it ain't broke don't
fix it hat das auto über 100 jahre
hinweg immer nur kleine verbesserungen
erhalten
die automarke hatten schließlich keinen
grund sich gedanken über alternative
antriebe zu machen solange der
verbrennungsmotor funktionierte aber wie
funktioniert überhaupt ein
verbrennungsmotor
gute frage hier eine kurze einfache
erklärung zylinder sind über eine
kurbelwelle mit einer nach verbunden
jeder der zylinder durchläuft die vier
phasen separat zuerst wird der
treibstoff in den zylinder gefüllt dann
wird der treibstoff unter hohem druck
komprimiert was jetzt kommt ist das
worum es geht der treibstoff explodiert
und kurbelt mit der freigesetzten
energie die kurbelwelle an
und am ende werden die abgase nach
draußen befördert bevor der zirkel
wieder von vorne losgeht
das hat auch einige zeit lang super
funktioniert aber inzwischen haben sich
die umstände etwas geändert wir wissen
zum beispiel dass es so etwas wie den
klimawandel gibt und auch die so endlos
erscheinenden fossilen brennstoffe sind
beim besten willen nicht endlos auf
kurze oder lange sicht müssen wir vom
verbrennungsmotor weg kommen sonst
fallen viele teile unseres modernen
lebens einfach auseinander
also schauen wir uns die alternativen an
viele unternehmen stecken im moment
millionen in die entwicklung von autos
mit einem wasserstoffantrieb
hierbei wird wasserstoff verbrannt der
dann einen elektrischen motor antreibt
das einzige abgas ist hierbei reines
sauberes wasser
klingt ziemlich gut oder wenn man davon
absieht dass man die energie die man aus
dem wasserstoff herausbekommen bei der
herstellung erstmal reinstecken muss und
dass bei diesem prozess 80 prozent der
energie verloren geht
außerdem ist die reichweite von
wasserstoffautos im optimalfall ähnlich
wie die von heutigen elektroautos und
deren batterien werden immer besser und
wasserstoff ist zudem ein relativ
gefährlicher stoff wir erinnern uns hier
an knallgas experimente aus der siebten
klasse in chemie
ok keine wasserstoffautos was gibt's
noch hybridautos hybridautos heißen so
weil sie zwei motoren haben einen
verbrennungsmotor und ein elektromotor
während man normal mit dem
verbrennungsmotor fährt wird die
batterie für den elektromotor aufgeladen
das passiert zum beispiel beim bremsen
wenn überschüssige energie sonst in form
von wärme verloren gegangen wäre
der elektromotor unterstützt dann den
verbrennungsmotor das ergebnis sind mehr
kilometer pro liter benzin das sorgt für
eine grünere umwelt und für mehr geld in
der tasche aber das ist immer noch nicht
die lösung für das problem weil
hybridautos immer noch fossile
brennstoffe benötigen also anstatt halbe
sachen zu machen können wir auch direkt
nur den elektrischen teil des
hybridautos nehmen und haben das
elektroauto und das funktioniert im
endeffekt wieder ein smartphone
du steckst des abends in die steckdose
und die batterie wird aufgeladen und
dann fährst du am nächsten morgen damit
rum kein wasserstoff kein benzin nur
eine batterie aber wie funktioniert dann
eigentlich ein elektromotor jemand eine
wirklich vereinfachte erklärung die eine
version des elektromotors der induktions
motor funktioniert
in dem teil des motors der sich nicht
bewegt wird durch eine induktion ein
magnetfeld hervorgerufen
naja eigen sind es direkt drei
magnetfelder und dadurch dass wir hier
mit wechselstrom arbeiten verändern sich
diese magnetfelder ständig durch eine
intelligente positionierung der
magnetfelder können wir in der mitte
einen magneten befestigen der immer von
nächst gelegene feld angezogen wird
er versucht also ständig das magnetfeld
vor ihn einzuholen wird es aber nie
schaffen und diese mechanische bewegung
ist unser antrieb die reichweite mit
solchen elektromotoren liegt inzwischen
je nach modell bei über 400 kilometern
ohne zwischendurch aufladen zu müssen
das reicht locker für 95 prozent aller
alltäglichen autofahrten und batterien
werden mit der zeit immer effizienter
und bald wird man noch weiterfahren
können
und selbst wenn man mehr als die
mögliche reichweite fahren muss kann man
an einem sogenannten super charger alle
zehn minuten ungefähr 100 kilometer
reichweite aufladen
klar das dauert ein wenig länger als
tanken aber nach vier stunden fahrt will
man sich auch meistens die beine
vertreten oder und strom tanken ist an
vielen stellen kostenlos das alleine
macht elektroautos auf lange sicht
attraktiver die energieeffizienz ist
hierbei übrigens mit circa 90 prozent um
einiges höher als beim wasserstoff auto
aber bei dem thema höre ich schon leute
sagen halt halt halt der strom der ins
elektroauto kommt wo doch sowieso mit
kohle und gas erzeugt ist das
elektroauto also nicht genauso dreckig
und schädlich wie benzin autos und das
stimmt auch zum teil allerdings würde
selbst ein elektroauto das
ausschließlich mit kohlestrom fährt
genauso viel co2 erzeugen wie ein sehr
effizientes benzin oder diesel auto das
liegt daran dass viele
verbrennungsmotoren viel mehr wärme
erzeugen und dadurch energie verlieren
die das elektroauto nutzen kann und mit
der zeit für die stromproduktion in
deutschland immer grüner und
nachhaltiger
somit wird das elektroauto von tag zu
tag umweltfreundlicher am ende kann ich
mir eigentlich nur einen grund
vorstellen warum man sich kein
elektroauto kaufen würde
und das ist der sound denn das
elektroauto ist einfach nur stumm
aber selbst der fahrspaß soll sogar noch
besser sein weil ein elektroauto direkt
reagiert wenn man aufs pedal tritt ohne
gänge beschleunigt so ein auto
geschmeidig und verdammt schnell
das tesla model s kommt von 0 auf 100 in
3,9 sekunden
klar der preis punktspielen noch eine
große rolle
große batterien kosten verdammt viel
geld und für die nächsten zehn jahre
werden herkömmliche autos günstiger sein
als vergleichbare elektroautos aber je
mehr elektroautos produziert werden
desto günstiger werden die einzelnen
teile und tesla hat bereits das model
für die angekündigt 2017 soll das auto
für die mittelklasse erscheinen preis
gerade einmal 35 tausend us dollar und
franken sollte man auch nicht vergessen
dass alleine senkt den preis schon mal
ordentlich
nachdem wir jetzt wissen dass
elektroautos unterm strich eigentlich
meistens besser sind und die autos der
zukunft höchstwahrscheinlich alle
elektrisch fahren werden sollten wir
ihnen macht danken
max gründete 2003 tesla motors und hat
mit seinem erfolgreichen elektroauto die
alteingesessenen autofirmen aufgerüttelt
denn nachdem sich an unseren benzinautos
100 jahre lang nichts grundlegendes
getan hat haben seit tesla all diese
firmen angefangen elektroautos
anzukündigen und rauszubringen
fortschritt kommt eben nicht von alleine
sondern muss von mutigen menschen
initiiert und vorangetrieben werden
was man ihr werden wir in 20 jahren alle
mit elektroautos fahren schreibt es mir
unten in die kommentare ich bin sehr
gespannt was ihr zu dem thema zu sagen
hat wenn ihr noch mehr über elektroautos
erfahren wollt verlinke ich euch unten
einen artikel von block way but while
der artikel hat mir beim erstellen des
videos unglaublich geholfen aber es gibt
noch so viele dinge über die ich nicht
gesprochen habe weil ich einfach keine
zeit hatte also wenn euch das thema
interessiert lest euch den artikel durch
das wirklich super spannend und super
umfangreich auf jeden fall eine
empfehlung von mir und noch ein tipp von
mir ich habe jetzt auch meinen eigenen
youtube channel auf doktor watson mache
ich habe jetzt auch wissenschafts videos
zu spannenden themen
das erste video ist schon online und der
erste link unten in der video
beschreibung bringt euch zu meinem neuen
kanal und mit einem klick auf den
abonnieren -button verpasst ihr auch
keine neuen videos also bis gleich auf
dem neuen kanal doktor watson